First we multiply by the LCD, rs on both sides of our equation. This gives us t
on the left side and, and the quantity t plus r times r on the right side. Next
we distribute the rt to these terms to get this equations. We subtract rt from
both sides to get t minus rt equals r squared. Remember, we want to solve for t
so let's get it on one side. I'm going to rewrite our equation up here and now
we have to factor. We want to get one t out of these two terms. If we factor our
t, we're left with t times 1 minus r equals r squared. Finally we divide by 1
minus r to get t is equal to r squared divided by 1 minus r. Fantastic work if
you got this. Now I know this is pretty challenging so don't worry if you don't
have the hang of it yet. Let's try working through a couple more and see if you
pick it up.